hey we are in front of a very special
thing today this is the East Coast
defender defender 130 project Viper this
is a very special custom truck it's
based off in 1986 Land Rover Defender
cost about two hundred eighty six
thousand dollars and it's meant to be
able to scale a mountain and look good
going to dinner so let's take a look
[Music]
this is pretty jacked up this is not a
low-key SUV this is really in your face
truck you kind of feel like you're in
Mad Max for your heroes in style here
when East Coast defender starts
designing this for you they literally
say what do you want us to do and you
can tailor things back based on price or
functionality but really the whole idea
is that you kind of make your fantasy
truck they're only going to make ten of
these per year so if you are interested
you got to really get on it because it
takes about a year to build one and ten
per year do the math there aren't many
people are going to have this
so even though this car is a defender it
actually has a lot of American
components and everything here was
assembled in the US so it's kind of cool
that's a British car but made in America
I will play though
the horn very British
[Music]
you